all right we're gonna continue with our
little retrospective on the x-men film
franchise pick up right where we left
off we're gonna get into X - x-men
United the first x-men was quite as good
as I remember - big this one though did
not disappoint this movie does so much
right it does so much better than it was
the first time because what happens is
if you do it right your first movie you
establish the origin you get all your
exposition out of the way your character
introductions etc etc etc then you get
to the sequel and you can really start
to just play with it everything that was
good about the first one is better about
this one and even the people who weren't
great the first time around are decent
this time around I'm looking at you
Halle Berry and there's some other
things there was something that I had
mentioned about the first excellent
movie that it was a bit
Wolverine centric now the reason that
bugged me in that film is there was no
particular reason for that one to be
Wolverine centric this time it makes
sense in its organic to the story
because this time we have our villain we
have William Stryker
because Wolverine is tied up with this
guy's past makes it logical that
Wolverine is gonna be central doesn't is
sorting all this out other thing that is
a huge improvement over the first x-men
is the addition of scope x-men one it
felt very small in terms of its scale
x-men 2 feels much bigger it feels
bigger for a number of reasons one the
stakes so much higher than they were in
the first film and even beyond that the
world is bigger because you know we're
just jumping around locations more but
here's the key not only does it have
scale but it manages to maintain the
sense of intimacy which was something
that the first film had and was a very
good thing to not lose it would have
been very easy in introducing scale to
lose the more tight-knit feeling that
the first film did have but it didn't
lose it it kept it in fact it built on
it even
new characters I'd like Nightcrawler it
just fits in seamlessly and I also want
to say they've done a really good job in
terms of introducing new x-men
whether it be someone heavily featured
like Nightcrawler or whether it be
someone literally just tossed in there
like Colossus that's a great way to just
introduce the character just have him
show up and kick a lot of butt
that right there is excellent fanservice
is what that is
the villains Magneto and mystique to
have them come back have them team up
with the good guys but not lose their
edge and that sort of temptation that
they had going on with pyro really
helped emphasize the power that may need
to has beyond just his mutant powers but
the enticement of other mutants and the
way he recruits to his cause now coming
back to William Stryker it was a great
idea to bring in a human villain because
before as I said when it was just mutant
versus mutant it was too insular let's
bring in a third party let's bring in
someone else who says you know what I've
had it with all you I'm taking you all
out and by having him be a human rather
than having you just be a bigger and
badder mutant like apocalypse or
something like that
it just helps reinforce all of the
important themes of x-men that have
helped it endure for so long in the
comic books the the prejudice the
outcasts that gets reinforced all the
stronger by having the human villain who
hates this group of people there's a
couple of stumbling points here it's not
a perfect film Cyclops kind of gets the
shaft he disappears for most of the
wrong time which a little bit of a
bummer Lady Deathstrike
as cool as she was and as cool as that
fight with Wolverine was she feels a
little underdeveloped but I mean theater
quibbles this thing holds up this is
probably still gonna rank is the best
x-men movie made to date so on that note
this council of geeks is adjourned